and it's fantastic to see you here today
at London Film and comic-con winter how
you enjoying it so far
fantastic loving it yeah it's really
good really good we've enjoyed seeing
you on Game of Thrones back on last
season a fortune we lost you didn't we
and that amazing scene with the Hound
and I er what was it like filming that
that was I was amazing big fan of the
show massive fan of our show and just to
her just to be given the opportunity to
be in four of the episodes was was very
exciting and loved it loved every minute
of it you know a little bit about behind
the scenes filming behind the scenes
filming it was all on location so kind
of a you know you're basically in fields
or cold alien fields and in Belfast and
I went to Ireland I'd never been to
Ireland before and Belfast absolutely a
beautiful beautiful place I loved it
loved the people my wife came out of me
we got to was length Europa there was
queues and queues of people because at
the Europa they were doing the MTV
Awards it was the after-party so when we
got in they gave us earplugs and and up
might pick up time in the morning to
film was 5:30 so it was sort of right
okay so you imagine we were in bed at 9
o'clock with earplugs in and sorry and
and and it was it was sort of when you
wear earplugs or you can do it yourself
snore so so it's weird and and the drum
and bass coming from Lady Gaga's
afterparty
so yeah and it was that was that was it
you know so it was behind the scenes
that lovely people lovely cars Maisie
winning Rory
wonderful Gerard Young played my my
sidekick biter it was a great great man
and I hope one day I can work again with
him and and you know maybe some of the
other guys you know I really enjoyed it
saw Maisie leave the hound and we at the
end of the season what do you think do
you think he's definitely gone for good
you don't Susan my eyes cry I was crying
yeah and that was a really really you
know heartfelt scene brilliant
brilliantly done by the pair of them you
know super stars and I hope he comes
back
there's more but I it's funny because I
believe that they were there there was
there's so many characters in the books
I've not read the books I own the books
but I don't think I'll ever open them up
I think I'll keep him but there was and
I think they were saying that they had
to they were having to mold some
characters together you know to try and
try and I guess to try and for everyone
in you know so so yeah so you know it
was just just amazing Tommy show you
plays Jack and her car of course who you
worked with and the past season might be
coming back I mean what do you think
about that I think William you know jack
and hacker
I'm Thomas you know wonderful wonderful
actor and he did he did so well in it
you know I can I can remember when we
were sitting in the in the prison truck
and and he was he was he was very
quietly spoken in it you know or you
know famously I thought well I want it
to be that I wanted to be the quiet a
smoke and one of how I played it but I
didn't get that opportunity it was kind
of like you know scream as much as you
could in there amazing but yes so I hope
it comes back I hope you know I'm we
think because I am along as I'm not read
the books when there's more though is
there I think there's more that that
character does later I'm not sure but I
hoping I'd become speckling talking
about screaming of course you were all
screaming at the screen and never was
screaming on the set when they were
watching the Viper vs the mountain
weren't they what was your reaction when
you saw it on TV
the easy heat is the easiest I've saw
him huge monster yeah I mean let's see
sir you know it's incredible you know
it's said that he I mean some of the
scenes that they you know that they do
the fight scenes and stuff like they're
you know they've very quickly you know I
mean when when the Hound takes on by
tones so you know
they know that that was sort of that
they rehearsed that only a couple of
times and did actually amazingly because
because that's it's not you're not doing
that honor on a mat or anything it's you
know I'm gonna throw your over onto the
cold wet muddy floor you know so so
obviously with that we know where the
hair is yeah amazing amazing
you